[Music]
can I compliment you
you always look fantastic you you
dressed to the netwo you don't work SS
thank you very much oh you you wear a
nice show a lot of the youngsters they
come on this show and they're wearing
their ponchos in their clothes me the
last person that world poncho
I don't know Chris Pine came on wear
night haunt you yeah reeking of
patchouli exactly well yes thank you you
are dress nicely and I I appreciate that
you dress up for us well I only for you
and for first communion which I've done
like 12 times
um I'm recent those wafers yeah gonna
know they're not cookies you know good
sacred wafer is our church now makes
like a ranch flavor that's just it's an
incentive to get people in oh oh yeah we
did Church more offices at Chipotle one
no thank you
I also recently got some leather pants
see Julia yes not on my not my choice um
no I for community which you can see me
in leather pants next week uh yeah it
was very odd they they look three people
watching do they yeah it was I got
fitted for leather pants and did what
how did they feel when you put him on
amazing no it was weird cuz I was like
wow I guess I am a German soccer player
and that's what I felt like and then you
put them on and uh then I felt like a
man for the first time but uh you you
know when you put a leather coat you're
like I'm hot I will now take the leather
coat off you can't do that with other
pants it's like a Easy Bake Oven down
here because it's already warm there
anyway but then you put leather on top
of it and boy yeah so so but it doesn't
smell like cake
just to be clear my question is how do
you know I have a pair of leather pants
he has a pair of leather pants no you
don't I really he does I have I haven't
worn them in years but yeah my wor my
wife my wife did the sage let me wait
you're blaming you wore leather pants
voluntarily yeah sure
in like New York when you want yeah
absolutely did you wear them out and
around like 19 you know the early
nineties oh yeah we're doing crazy stuff
like that back then
and I don't remember that in the early
90s at all oh that's no excuse oh like
some huge dominatrix baby put your
finger on my wife's particular fetish
oh why do you sir finger on what you
know my wife is into you know the big
S&M baby we've got all you know you know
what so and so are the Grammys all those
things you show up to work in yes you
know what this is a fact
I am an old late night show Andy did
come to work wearing the leather pants
yes he did
how did you not die of ridicule I mean I
want to keep I don't say he pulled it
off yeah you thought they were awesome I
thought he looked cool yeah I'm what's
known as incredibly confident
[Applause]